The single best piece of advice I ever got was
let the dad struggle 100%.
He's not gonna do it the same way you do.
When I was pregnant with my first,
I remember hearing a lot that
moms become moms during pregnancy
and dads become dads after birth.
I think a lot of that is held over from this idea
that a pregnant woman is somehow
going to just know what to do when the baby comes out,
that instincts are gonna tap in
and you're just gonna be a super mom from day one.
So although that can be true,
that there's that instant instinct kicking,
it's not true 100% of the time.
What is true is that the birthing parent or mother
is usually the primary parent of that infant.
So even if you don't know what to do,
you learn trial by fire.
You are in it from day one,
whereas dad might be a little bit slow out of the game.
So as much as it is easy for you to just do bedtime,
you to do every feed,
um, you gotta let the guy struggle.
There is no reason that a dad
or non birthing partner is in any way
less capable than the person who gave birth.
And the sooner that that baby can be soothed
by both of you,
the sooner you guys are gonna
get back to a little bit more equal playing field.
And there's truly nothing better than watching
Your husband
becoming truly caring,
capable and confident. Dad